ouverture ici à Paris de la conférence
d'aide à l'Ukraine et l'intervention du
président Macron madame la Présidente de
la Commission européenne chirurcella
Mesdames et Messieurs les premiers
ministres
Mesdames et Messieurs les directeurs et
secrétaires généraux d'organisation
internationales
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
Mesdames et Messieurs les Ambassadeurs
mesdames et messieurs je voudrais avant
tout remercier chacun de vous et à
travers vous tous les états et
organisations que vous représentez pour
votre présence aujourd'hui à Paris pour
cette conférence
c'est une preuve tangible que l'Ukraine
n'est pas seul
en effet 46 pays 24 organisations
internationales ont répondu à l'appel de
l'Ukraine et de la France pour ce moment
de mobilisation internationale que nous
avons choisie d'appeler solidaire avec
le peuple ukrainien
car la présence en nombre dans cette
salle de représentant d'État du monde
entier et j'insiste bien sur ce point et
je remercie la présidence de l'azéanne
et Cambodge jetla aussi tout
particulièrement largement au-delà de
l'Europe donc est d'organisation
internationale couvrant des domaines
d'une grande diversité témoignent de la
force de l'élan et de la solidarité de
la communauté internationale en soutien
à l'Ukraine
depuis bientôt 10 mois l'Ukraine résiste
avec bravoure et détermination à
l'agression russe déclenchait le 24
février
oserai-je dire cette fois-ci ouvertement
car rappelons-nous que cette agression
avait débuté en 2014
sans tout à fait l'assumer à l'époque
mais que c'est en réalité près de 9 ans
que les Ukrainiens ont connu
de guerre
sous la violence extrême ou de garde je
veux rendre ici aux marges aux forces
armées ukrainiennes qui ont repoussé
l'offensive russe contre Kiev et qui
sont parvenus à reprendre grâce à leur
courage et à leur abnégation tant de
territoires et je veux rendre hommage au
peuple ukrainien dans son ensemble qui
malgré l'horreur des crimes commis par
l'occupant russe
à dans des villes comme Mario Paul
bouchapine
izum et tant d'autres garder les
stigmates et gardera encore longtemps
les stigmates de cette cruauté le peuple
craignant disait continue de se battre
avec une détermination admirable pour
son pays et pour sa liberté
la reprise de Carson à la mi-novembre
démontre
l'inanité des simulacre de référendum
que la Russie avait organisé pour tenter
d'annexer 4 régions du crâne et que la
communauté internationale a condamné à
une écrasante majorité à l'Assemblée
générale des Nations Unies
depuis que l'Ukraine a repris le dessus
sur le terrain la Russie dont les
faiblesses au plan militaire ont été
exposées au grand jour à opté pour une
stratégie cynique visant à détruire les
infrastructures civiles en vue de mettre
l'Ukraine à genoux
à chaque victoire de votre pays sur le
terrain la Russie réagit lâchement par
de nouveaux bombardements des
infrastructures électriques gazières ou
de distribution de l'eau nécessaire à la
survie de la population pendant l'hiver
avec un objectif clair
en réponse au défaite militaires se met
la terreur chez les civils tenter de
briser l'arrière faute de pouvoir tenir
le front et c'est frappes qui visent
ouvertement les populations et les
infrastructures civiles s'effrappent
dont la Russie avoue ouvertement qu'elle
ne vise qu'à saper la résistance du
peuple ukrainien constitue des crimes de
guerre elle viole sans aucun doute
possible les principes les plus
fondamentaux du droit humanitaire ces
actes sont intolérables et ne resteront
pas impunis
je veux ici être clair
dans ce contexte c'est à l'Ukraine
victime de cette agression de décider
des conditions d'une paix juste et
durable et à cet égard chervelo Dimir le
plan de paix en 10 points que tu as
exposé constitue une excellente base sur
laquelle nous allons bâtir ensemble
mais dans l'immédiat l'urgence consiste
à soutenir la capacité du peuple
ukrainien à résister
c'est pour permettre à l'Ukraine de
traverser cet hiver le plus long que
nous avons souhaité organiser ensemble
cette conférence appelée solidaire avec
le peuple ukrainien dont nous avons
souhaité que les résultats soient très
concrets premièrement il s'agit en toute
chose de mobiliser nos partenaires les
amis de l'Ukraine les pays engagés dans
le soutien humanitaire et les bailleurs
internationaux pour fournir une aide
concrète en permettant de préserver le
fonctionnement des infrastructures
critiques que j'évoquais et permettre à
la population de tenir cet hiver
l'énergie l'eau l'alimentation la santé
les transports les vêtements et j'espère
que nos engagements collectifs seront à
la hauteur
des enjeux et vous aideront à faire face
aux besoins les plus urgents de cet
hiver nous apporterons une aide
exceptionnelle pour ce qui est de la
France nous avons d'ores et déjà
déboursé 151,5 millions d'euros depuis
le début de l'année nous rage entrons
48,5 millions d'euros séjour-ci pour les
priorités identifiées dans le cadre de
la conférence 27 millions sur l'urgence
huernale le reste répartit entre les
personnes déplacées les violences
sexuelles les enfants l'aide alimentaire
la santé mentale et nous allons en plus
de ça ajouter une contribution
exceptionnelle de 76,5 millions d'euros
dans le domaine de l'électricité de
l'énergie pour l'acquisition de l'aide
dans le cadre de l'Initiative coordonnée
avec la Commission européenne dont
madame la Présidente reparlera dans un
instant
63 nouveaux générateurs électriques de
haute puissance et plusieurs
transformateurs en complément des 100
déjà livrés en novembre mais également
des financements pour l'eau l'aide
alimentaire la santé ce qui portera un
effort total en plus de ce qui est déjà
été fait à 125 millions d'euros d'aide
d'urgence
ce soutien est essentiel je remercie
tous les pays aussi pour leur
contribution annoncée à l'occasion de
cette conférence deuxièmement nous avons
fait ensemble chervolo Demir le constat
que la coordination de l'aide d'urgence
devait être perfectionnée et amélioré
pour répondre de manière très
opérationnelle aux besoins de l'Ukraine
et nous l'évoquons hier avec le Premier
ministre de Norvège l'est aussi évoqué
avec le Premier ministre du Luxembourg
nous avons besoin que les choses
arrivent concrètement sur le terrain et
nous avons appris des conflits passés et
donc au delà des conférences où l'on
annonce des montants il nous faut une
coordination très étroite avec des
points de contact dans tous les pays
pour que l'aide arrive en temps réel sur
le terrain
et à l'issue d'un dialogue étroit avec
le crâne et les services de la
Commission européenne que je remercie
vivement pour cela au cours de ces
dernières semaines nous pouvons annoncer
aujourd'hui la mise en place d'un
mécanisme renforcé de coordination de
l'aide internationale ce que tu as
qualifié dimanche cher volo dimires de
mécanisme de Paris s'appuiera sur le
mécanisme de protection civile de
l'Union européenne qui joue déjà
aujourd'hui un rôle précieux et sera
étendu aux États volontaires désireux de
prendre part à l'effort de soutien
plusieurs États non européens présents
aujourd'hui parmi nous ont ainsi désigné
des points de contact en vue d'intégrer
ce mécanisme et je salue
particulièrement ces pays qui démontrent
qu'il n'est pas besoin d'être un pays
occidental pour être convaincu de la
nécessité de soutenir l'Ukraine dans la
durée
ce mécanisme centré sur l'aide d'urgence
s'inscrit ainsi en complémentarité avec
la coordination de l'aide en matière
d'énergie impulsée par les États-Unis
dans le cadre du G7 et le mécanisme pour
la reconstruction que nous avons
clarifié sous président allemand du G7
c'est initiatives cette conférence
aujourd'hui
vient si je puis dire compléter
accompagner une série d'événements
internationaux majeurs qui ont marqué
ces derniers mois je pense bien sûr à la
conférence de Lugano que vous avez
accueillie en juillet dernier Monsieur
le Président de la Confédération sherine
et qui a permis à l'Ukraine de présenter
son plan de reconstruction et qui a posé
les principes fondamentaux de la
reconstruction de l'Ukraine je pense à
la conférence de Berlin co-organisé fin
octobre par l'Allemagne et la Commission
européenne sur cela est cher en Alena
qui a donné lieu à des discussions
fructueuses entre experts sur la
coordination de la reconstruction de
long terme de l'Ukraine et nous nous
réunirons l'année prochaine à Londres
pour poursuivre cet engagement dans la
durée aux côtés de l'Ukraine car nous
serons aussi aux côtés de l'Ukraine
quand elle aura enfin mené à son terme
salut lutte pour la liberté
la France entend dès aujourd'hui aussi
jouer son rôle en termes de
reconstruction et j'ouvrirai cet
après-midi avec vous monsieur le Premier
ministre un forum économique en présence
de près de 700 entreprises qui permettra
de mobiliser celle-ci sur l'aide
d'urgence et d'accompagner les
investissements à plus long terme en
Ukraine
enfin au-delà de l'état de nos
entreprises permettez-moi de saluer la
mobiliser la mobilisation de l'ensemble
de la société française au service de
l'Ukraine nous avons réuni le 8 décembre
autour de Madame la Ministre Colonna des
acteurs non-étatiques et notamment nos
collectivités territoriales en plus de
leur accueil de réfugiés Ukrainiens 1800
collectivités ont contribué à hauteur de
9,5 millions d'euros à un fond d'aide à
l'Ukraine et nous les avons incités à
faire de nouvelles contributions en
faveur de l'aide hivernale d'urgence les
plus hauts représentants de l'Assemblée
nationale du Sénat des collectivités
territoriales et des ONG Français sont
aujourd'hui avec nous dans cette salle
et je les en remercie c'est l'équipe de
France qui est se faisant mobiliser et
je sais que plusieurs pays présents
autour de la table fonctionnent de la
même manière et qu'au-delà des
engagements du jour apporte
soutien au quotidien extrêmement concret
et je veux les en remercier voilà ce que
je voulais dire en ouverture de cette
conférence chersvelo d'imir et je veux
ici te dire que tu as à Paris des Chefs
d'État de gouvernement au côté de ton
épouse et du Premier ministre est de
plusieurs de tes ministres qui sont
pleinement mobilisés qui ont la volonté
de se battre et d'être solidaire au
peuple ukrainien et
jusqu'au dernier jour et à la dernière
minute de ne rien lâcher de ce soutien
car le combat que veut mener est un
combat pour votre liberté votre
souveraineté mais c'est aussi un combat
pour l'ordre international et pour notre
stabilité à tous
de te passer la parole et merci d'être
avec nous